ten four i got the kid
uh 46 of you want to bring the mother
this way he's not crying or anything but
this is confirming we have the car and
the baby
10-4 it's unoccupied besides the child
mysterious
she's going to the alley
[Music]
what's that dog watch that dog
come here
get in there right now
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
which way did it go she was going that
way and she was going all crazy but she
was inside the stripes so they had
videos
but if i can find my phone
my phone is in the car and i can find
out where my car's at
[Music]
it's going to be a female
it's going to be a female driver
the mom tried to she pushed the mom out
of the way mom jumped on the hood she
drugged the bomb if you could start a 55
mom's got several abrasions
and i have two babies in there a
six-year-old
i don't know how to do it
i think we have officers that found the
vehicle
[Music]
[Music]
you have an 11 month old a boy and a
girl 11 month old and a six-year-old in
the car
just for 49 there's an 11 month old and
a six-year-old in the vehicle
[Music]
all right give us your hands right now
you're going to be 10. i know all right
you're ready
whoever went to the other side
i saw her this was something i'm going
inside the backyard because we thought
she was going to jump and she turned
around came right back towards me
we hopped on that side yes you get right
back towards me now like i gotta trap
all the way
down